there are 50 slots on the training tab
and when I last checked 22 of them were
taken up by either a movie trailer to
deal 8 night host big brand or TV show
this is ridiculous when you account for
the fact that YouTube only has 3 main
tabs to exploit their entire site and in
one of them about half the options are
TV related which means their main
product isn't even on YouTube it's just
an advertisement to go watch their show
or movie so in other words the trending
tab has become a glorified TV Guide this
problem isn't new trending has been
frustrating youtubers since 2015 you see
it all started when YouTube released the
cryptic statement about what kinds of
videos would be featured some trends are
predictable like a new song from a
popular artist or a new movie trailer
are surprising like a viral video we aim
to surface videos that a wide range of
viewers will find interesting and novel
now this got people excited because it
seemed like a great way to feature new
viral creators but that's not really
what happened in the end it's led to a
stagnant predictable system where every
day it seems like a mash-up of John
Oliver meets BuzzFeed Bleu dominated by
videos that have lots of marketing
resources behind them whether that be
Business Insider the NFL SNL what the
hell oh wait that's Casey Neistat on
trending again but he sponsored by CNN
so it's okay and why is this happening
is there conspiracy where YouTube's
trying to promote big-budget movies or
TV shows I don't think so but whenever
you rely on an algorithm to sort things
people are gonna find a way to exploit
and optimize for that algorithm when
YouTube started the turning tab they
knew they didn't want already big
youtubers dominating the space every day
with their videos that consistently got
millions of views and that makes sense
PewDiePie on training every day would
get super old but how do you find viral
videos when you can't use view count as
an indicator of virality what YouTube's
solution was to base who gets on the
training tab on a variety of factors how
fast is the video growing where the
views coming from geographically but
most of all where's the traffic being
driven from this last factor is really
important because it explains how the
Time Warner tab came to be because if
your main way to push content is through
YouTube you're not considered viral by
YouTube because all your traffic is
internal but if you're someone like
Jimmy Kimmel and people love to share
your crying monologues across Twitter
then your video is going to hit the
training page because the views from
Twitter account it is more valuable
because it's coming from a
raus platforms this is why BuzzFeed
GoPro Business Insider big brands hit
the trinity page so often because they
have huge marketing teams that spread
their content across all the platforms
while independent YouTube creators tend
to focus on YouTube I want to talk for a
moment why having the system this way is
a bad thing first
YouTube is not great because it houses
the highlights of TV YouTube is great
because it isn't TV it isn't or at least
wasn't dominated by big corporations it
was governed by a meritocracy of
independent creators in fact the whole
reason for YouTube's popularity is
thanks to these people so when YouTube
makes one of the key navigation options
of their website accessible to a small
minority of youtubers and to a large
majority of advertisers and TV
influencers it seems like a bad move and
a step away from who they are at their
core and in a weird way
I'd prefer one of YouTube's own
clickbait monsters getting featured over
going back to the same TV culture of
recycled over polish stuff that I could
watch on the TV I no longer pay for
because the Internet is better
I was Nebraska better than North Dakota
is that jokes only funny in Nebraska
that joke is not funny here second it
isn't like we don't know where to find
these brands or TV shows if we wanted to
watch them why shove them down my throat
I already know who Seth Meyer is why not
show someone who's blowing up on YouTube
that I haven't heard of I mean in a way
it's kind of ironic the trianing tab was
designed not to over promote the already
huge channels of YouTube but it ended up
doing exactly that only instead of
promoting their own they're over
promoting the very media structures that
they replaced a decade ago and before
you say okay but what about creator on
the rise and that is a start but
consider this there are 2 million people
eligible to be a creator on the rise
which means that every day if you were
dealt a hand of cards you draw a Royal
Flush three times before you got
featured on the creator on the rise page
it's a gesture that looks good but is
pretty meaningless now given YouTube's
incredible track record of listening to
creators I don't think this is going to
change anytime soon so it might be worth
saying if your youtuber and you ever
want a shot at hitting the
TV Guide of YouTube you might want to
focus on diversifying where your views
come from because being successful on
YouTube isn't enough you've got to have
a large audience off YouTube which is a
lot easier to do when your main product
isn't YouTube so in the spirit of that
if you like this video you can help my
channel by liking my Twitter page and my
facebook page linked in the description
below and retweet and share this video
if enough people watch and share this
video from other social media sites who
knows we might just end up on the
training page but probably not I need my
CNN sponsorship to come in first
[Music]
you